そういうわけで 仏教ではいつでも人にはね
死ぬということはもう自分の身近な事実として
それに頭の中でなければいけませんと
それがなければ人がもうどうなるとわからないし
本当に亡くなってからいいところに生きたければ
自分がいつでも死ぬかもしれませんという
この死はいつでも一番身近な事実
死だけ身近な事実なんです
他のものはもう可能性だけ
確かではないんですね
何一つも確かではない
もう将来金持ちになるかという
もう確かじゃない じゃあ破産するか
どっちでも確かではない
死ぬまで健康的にいられるかないかという
一つも確かじゃない でも確かな事実というのは
一番身近な事実っていうのは
世の中で死ぬということなんですね
それはもうそうじゃないと思っている
この世の中の人々はいかに無知かということも考えてほしいんですね
それだけは考えない それだけは考察しない
研究もしない で また威張っちゃうんですね
すごい知識人だと ですからもう研究する課題はやっぱり死という課題であって
それに考えなくちゃいけない課題も死ということなんですね
で その人々がやっぱりそれを考えること自体もいいことであって
そのカルマによってでもいいところに生まれ変わっちゃうし
心はきれいになりますからね
死を考える人は 人はいつ死ぬかわからないんだと
確実に死ぬことだけ確かだということは
自分の一番の真理として持っている人は全然悪いことをしませんし
喧嘩もしませんし もう人々といちいちまあ延々と恨みやら憎しみやら持って
もう気持ち悪く生きることもしないし
心清らかに楽しく明るく生きるんです
なぜならばいつ死ぬかわからないんだから
で 知らないという人々は
人と恨み買ったら 永久的にその恨み死ぬまで持っていくんですね
死ぬ時は遺言書書く時でも
それで書いて死んじゃうんです
だからそこまで恨みを持っていくんですね
だからその人々はもう決して幸福にはならないんです
そういうことで この死ぬんだとわかった人がずっといいことをしてこなかったかもしれません
まあそろそろ終わりだなとわかったら
それからでも遅くないんです
いいことをするのは ですから
もうそういう死ぬ間際でも何かいいことをしたならば
そのインパクトでどこかで生まれ変われる
それはいいことの場合なんで
例えば一生素晴らしいことをしていた人が
突然何か悪いことをやってしまったというと
その人はその通りになってしまったわけです
だからこのいい方向も悪い方全部五分五分なんです
その方がはっきりしますね
例えばずっといいことをして生活していた人が
何か出来事 何かあって
もう悪いことをしてしまったと
そうするとすごくすごいショックなんですね
なんで私はこんなことをやってしまったんですかと
ですから もうその人も死ぬ時はもうやっぱり悪いところに行ってしまっちゃうんです
だからインパクトの強い行為が結果を出しちゃうんです
で そういう風なこのインパクト強い業が
最近やった業がない場合はアーチーナカンマというこの業が働くんですね
うん アーチーナっていうのは
このまあほとんど毎日のように
まあよくもう一般的にまあ癖みたいな感じでやってるいいことなんですね
もう慣れてしまってるんです
まあいい例で いい例でならばわかりやすい例でならば
例えばこのまあ 両親が亡くなった子供を何とかして育てようと
誰か何か施設作るんだと
それでこじゅうあつけて面倒見る
そうするとその人 それはずっとやらなくちゃいけないでしょうに
で まあ彼が考えることも
彼の行動も お金儲かることもいろいろ
あの 資金が集まることをなんだかんだも自分作った施設の運営のために一生懸命やっていて
そこでその人は死ぬ時でもずっとやってきた仕事だから
そこそこはもう忘れることはないんですね
慣れてるんだから ですから
長い間何かいいことをし続けると
その人はやっぱりこの習慣になっているんだから
それをもうすぐ思い出しちゃうんです
ですから 習慣的になっている業が働くんですね
3番目 働いて次の生まれが決める
悪い例で言うならば もうずっと毎日酒飲んでそれだけ楽しんでる人が急に病気になって病院に運んじゃったら
一番先に困るのは何ですか？って
あ 酒飲めなくなったと病院で言うんだ
やっぱり習慣として毎日のように飲んで飲んでるんだから
まあもう他の何か病気で病院に運んだりしたってでもまあその次回になってくると
病院だからやっぱり酒が飲めないんだということが頭に思い浮かんじゃう
死ぬ時でも同じ法則で
それは頭に浮かんでしまったんですね
習慣としてやってくるもの
苦集業ですね  4番目 カッタ
もし苦集業もなかったならば
カッタっていうのはやったことがあるという意味なんです
うん そうですね こっちキサゴという
イサ イサゴ まあやったことは何かカルマが働くんですね
大体死ぬ時は人の頭は朦朧とするんでしょう
盲目しちゃうでしょうに
そこでいろんなこと見えちゃうんです
何が見えるかとも決まってないんです
自分今までやったことやらいろんな現象も頭の中でぐるぐるぐるぐる回っちゃうんですね
だからその中で何かサッとインパクトがあって捕まっちゃうんです
まあですからまあ心っていうのは
もう目で見て喋ってる時はいくらかあのわからないんで
心の働きっていうのは
この目で耳の体の機能が
この機械の機能が弱くなっちゃったら
心が随分暴走し始めるんですね
心はこの考えることを止めません
ですから 目で何も何も見ていない時
耳で何も聞いてない時とかね
もう体の機能が抑えちゃうと心がもう暴走始めちゃうんです
我々この幻覚とか ああだこうだというのは心の暴走なんですね
コントロールはなくなっ
で それでまあ自分が今世であろうか
過去世であろうかもう輪廻の中でやった何を思い出すかわからないんですね
死んだ瞬間で 心は自分だけで暴走して始まるんだから
心というものには私はいつでも言ってますから
時間はないと心には 心は物体ではないんだから
物体には時間があるんです
心は物質じゃないんだから時間がないんです
ですから もう過去もないし
現在ということもいつでも現在なんです
だからもう人としてどんな過去でやったことでも心には今なんです
そういうことで心だけ自由に行動すると
我々の俗的な次元で言うならば
どんな過去のことを思い出せるんです
我々なぜ思い出せないかというと
これ体に束縛されているんだからなんです
今は心は体についてしまってねじで
動けないんですね 自由に
目から入る情報 耳から入る情報しか思い出せないんです
そのねじを外すちゃえば
もう時空関係と関係なくもう発動する
ですから 死ぬ時 死ぬ瞬間ではもう何億年前でも
もうものすごい昔でもやった業が思い浮かぶ可能性あるんです
あって次に生まれちゃうんですね
その業によって ですから
人が死んだら生まれ変わらないということはあり得ない
なぜならば 死ぬ瞬間になってきたら
どんな人の心ももう暴走始まるんです
それは避けられないんです
体が弱くなって死ぬんだから
体が弱くならないで死ぬ人はいないんです
じゃあ二十歳の人が事故ですぐぽっくり死んだと言ったらどうですか？その場合
同じことなんです 車が体の上に走ってしまったというと
体がバラバラぐちゃぐちゃになるでしょう
それで体が壊れているんだから
その時間十分なんです
心に 考えるために で 体からすぐ抜けちゃう
体から情報入らなくなっちゃう
もう脳細胞も全部もう壊れてしまうでしょうに
そのまあ一秒間の百分の百も十分ですよ
膨大な量のことを妄想できます
ですから体が壊れて死なない人はいないんです
誰でも体が壊れることで死ぬんです
人間でいえば 人間と動物でいえば
ですから心は暴走することはもう確実にあることで
その時はその何かを掴まるということも確実にあることで生まれてしまうんですね
次のところに まあそういうふうな四つのグループに分けているんです
ジャナカサン 冷静業 次の四つ
うん その一番目はヴィパッサナー瞑想に当たる
この四つは長いんですね
名前が 一番目ディッダダンマヴェーダニーヤ
このパーリ文字は長いんだけど
まあそれはまあしょうがないんですけど
ディッダダンマっていうのは今世という意味なんですね
いわゆる present 今という意味なんですね
その意味で使っている言葉
だからこの辞書だけ引いてパーリ語を勉強する人にはちょっと危ないところあります
ダンマですからね こちらにあるのは
これは法とか訳しちゃったらちょっと変わるんです
それでディッダっていうのは
辞書を引いたら見たという過去分詞なんです
でもこれは見たという過去分詞で
これは法ですから 法を見たということになってしまうんですね
だからもうどうなるか分からない
意味は ディッダダンマっていうのはその意味ではないんです
この場合はダンマはnatureという意味なんですね
いわゆる何々性とか書くでしょ
可能性とかね この漢字でね
あの性という意味なんですね
だからこの まあどんな漢字にでも性入れちゃったら
もう意味がね それなりに変わるでしょうし
確実と書くと意味は確実
確実性といえばまた意味が変わるでしょ
そんな風なこの その意味なんですね
ダンマっていうのは ディッダっていうのは見られるということで
ですから見られることできるとというふうな
もうちょっと難しいんですけど
定義は とにかくディッダダンマっていうのは
今ここで今世っていう意味なんです
で 見られるんです ですから
もし人が何かしたとする
したならばそちらの結果が得られると
それはもう見られるんですね
人は万引きする 捕まれると
そこでいろいろ厳しく
もう大変恥に慣れると
例えば会社の人々もストレスたまっちゃって万引きする場合あるみたいですけどね
そこで普通のサラリーマンで普通のもう立派な仕事をしていて
ストレスたまっちゃって道書いて万引きするだとすると
捕まるでしょうに 捕まってそれ会社に報告したところでどうなるんですかね
その人が もう仕事クビになるかもしれません
大変なことになるんですね
そこで自分がやったことの結果が得て
それから不幸を味わわなくちゃいけないんですね
だから結果見られてるでしょうに
誰にでも その意味なんです
ディッダダンマっていうのは
[背景の音楽]人を殺したら裁かれる
それもディッダダンマ・ウェーディニヤ・カンマなんです
親孝行しない人々は 大体自分も同じ運命になっちゃうんです
自分の子供も全く親孝行しないようになってきます
そういうのはもう世の中ではもうみんな知ってることで
で 二番目はウパパッジャ・ウェーディニヤ
ウパッジャ ウパっていうのは後で
うーんと これは分析 日本語で分析するのは難しいかな
まあ次にと訳せ まあ次に
えーと 結果出すと 次っていうのは死んでから
死んで次の生で結果を出す
こっちは事象従と書いてますけど
で あの前説明したように
例えば母親殺したならば
その人は死んだら確実に次の生で
次の生まれで地獄に落ちちゃうでしょうし
それはウパパッジャ・ウェーディニヤなんですね
そこで母親を殺した人はそれから死ぬまで悩んだりするでしょうに
自分がやったことを 悪い
悪いことをやっちゃったんだから
死ぬまで悔やむでしょうし
それはディッダダンマ・ウェーディニヤ
あんた今悩んでるのは悪いことしたんだからですと
そこで死んでからその人地獄に落ちるし
その場合はウパパッジャ・ウェーディニヤなんです
何か行為をしたならば
今世で結果が出る場合もあるし
次に生まれて結果が出る場合もあるし
そこでアパラ・パリアっていうのは
後という 後々 もう後でいつかという意味なんですね
で 次の生まれで結果出さなかったならば
後でいつか結果出すんです
いわゆるやった行為を結果出さないで消えることはできないんです
で 業は心のことだから
心にはもう過去現在未来ないんだから
行動するのは心なんですね
私は手を挙げるのは心なんです
心があるんだから手を挙げてるんです
人を殴ったら それ私に心があるんだから人を殴るんであって
心がなかったんだから人を殴ろうとしない
心に怒りが出てきて そのエネルギーが出てきて体を動かしちゃう
そこで人を殴ったりする
ですから その心には過去もないし
未来もないし いつでも今のという状態でいるんです
ですからもうやったことの影響は消えません
それ思い出すか思い出さなかったという問題じゃないんです
思い出せないというのは
この体にねじでつけられてるんだからなんです
心は ただそれだけのこと
鳥を檻に入れてるんだから飛べないでしょうし
だから鳥が飛べないという人がいますかね
檻を開けちゃったら飛ぶんだから
ですから我々の心を体っていう檻に入れてるんだから
もう思い出せないだけで
檻を破れちゃったらもうどこにでも行けると
そういうことだから この何か悪いことしたらそれは消えません
結果は出すんです いつでもいつか
そういう業にアパラ・パリア・ウェーディニヤと言うんです
あ こちらウェーディニヤということは言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
アパラ・パリア・カンマでも分かりますけど
アホーシ・カンマっていうのは
これいろんな人々が何か誤解している場合もありますけど
ある人が仏教を研究して
このアホーシ・カンマで何ですか？やっぱりわからなくなっちゃったんですね
で なぜわからないと 僕は何であんたそれわからないこと聞いたんだけど
やっぱりこれすごい研究しなくちゃいけないんだと
なんか情報知ってるならば教えてください
僕は別に情報なんかないんだと
で まあそれで自分で研究して何か発見した？何も発見してないと思いますけど
説明はしてあげたんだけど
で なんで間違ってるかというと
このアホーシっていうのは事象で引くんです
というのは be動詞の過去形なんです
be動詞の いわゆる was という意味なんです
be動詞はね is am are と現在形でしょ
で 過去形は was と were でしょ
ですから このというのは be動詞の過去形なんですね
アオリストってパーリ語で言うんですけどね
アオリスト だからあるという意味のあったという意味なんです
いるという動詞のいたという意味なんですね
この場合あるですから
その人はカルマ業であった
あった業って何ですかと
わからなくなっちゃう
その場合は あった業 研究しなくちゃいけないと思って
結構研究していたんだけど
だからもうやたらに辞書を引いたって意味が取れない
そこはあるんですね ちゃんとそれはやっぱりちゃんとパーリ語を追って勉強しなくちゃ
で ここでっていうのはもうその意味ではなくて
ちょっとすごく ちょっと複雑な考え方なんですね
ここで言うのは この業はあったんだけど
結果は出せなかった だから結果を出す機会が失った
そういうわけで もう業はもうあったことにする
いわゆる今はないことにする
心に業はいつでもあることで
心にはね いつでも心は今でしょう
心には時間ないんだから
ですから 心にはいつでも業があるんです
もし心に業があった状態になったならば
その業はもう機能しないということなんです
いわゆる結果出せない業なんです
あの結果出すにしたっても
業は必ずしも結果出すといっても
結果出せる機会がなければ
どうしようもない 人は人を殺したとする
日本で その人はもう隠れちゃう
20年ぐらい 隠れてそれから社会に出ると
だからどうしようもない
その場合は 人を殺したってことを知ってるのに
もう裁けない 日本の法律によってもう時効になっているんだから
ですから その人は刑務所で苦しみを味わえないんです
それは世俗的な論で だからその人 20年間大変楽しく遊んで
もう堂々生活したかどうか
それは別な話でね もしかすると刑務所に行ったら 10年で終わるかもしれませんし
そこはちゃんと安心して生活できるし
ちゃんとご飯あるし ちゃんと運動する時間もあるし
読みたい本は読みたい本は読めるし
見たいテレビは見られるし
ですからまあ  20年間逃げて逃げたことで
もっとひどい業を受けたかもしれませんだけど
法律的な立場で言うならば
もうどうしようもない
そこでその人は堂々ともう警察官にあってもね
あんた知ってますけどね
私は何とか何年でね 何々さんがこうこうやって殺したんですよ
でも何もできません そんな感じで
この業には結果出せる機会がなくなっちゃったら
アホしか目になります
例えば 我々には限りない業が心に溜まってるんです
いくら生まれ変わっても終わらない
だから我々は本当はこの使っている業より作る業の方が多い
いつでも だからほんのわずかな業の償いをするんだけど
その間でもの大量の業を作ってるんです
ですから カルマはもう決して消えないものになっているんです
増える一方で減らない
例えば我々毎日生きることも業だから
毎日我々は貪瞋痴の衝動で人と喋ったり
行動したり 活動したりするでしょうに
全部業なんです 全部いつか結果出せるように溜まっちゃうんです
だから 1時間にどれぐらい業を行うかというと
もうキリがないんですね
だからこれを全部結果出すというと大変なこと
それでこの人の業っていうのは
もうあの それなりの報いとかなんとかとかね
して終わるものじゃないんです
悪い方もいい方も同じことなんですね
贅沢して自分の分は全部消えたということもないし
で 苦労したんだから業が消えるということもないんです
で それでだからと誤解してはいけないんです
だから贅沢やりたいほどやりましょうと
なぜかというと ここで人間で生まれたら
ある一項のカルマが働いてるんです
その 一項のカルマにはもうエネルギーは決まってるんです
このカルマが今世で終わっちゃうんです
今世で人間で我々が生まれた業が死ぬと終わっちゃうんです
それは早く食べてしまっちゃえば
その人にとってはもうどうしようもないんです
ですから そこもすごいなんか悔しいシステムなんです
例えば過去世の業を考えちゃうと
我々はいかに贅沢したっても消えないほどのいい業も溜まってるんです
いかに酷い目に遭ったっても
消えないほど悪い業も溜まってるんです
だからといって人間に生まれたところで
思い存分遊んでやろうかなと思ってたら
それまたできない 今世で生まれた業がもうこれということはもうちゃんと決まってるんだから
生まれる瞬間って その業が持ってるエネルギーで死ぬまで生きていなくちゃいけない
だからやっぱりその場合も節約して節約した方がいいんです
だから結局システムが悔しいんです
不公平じゃないんだけど
ちゃんと法則なんですけど
我々の欲望から見ればものすごい悔しいんじゃないかと
過去世でいろんないいことをしていたならば
なんで今世で私はこうこうなってるんですかと文句言ったって意味がないんです
今世で我々生まれた業が今世で死ぬまで我々の運命を左右するんですね
ですから いくらか贅沢できるような形で生まれた人々が
もう 20歳になるときは遊びたい放題遊んではっちゃったら
それからもう死ぬまで苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
もう業が消えて切れてるんだから
そこでこの 何て言いますか
生まれたものを支えてくれる業もありまして
邪魔をする業がありますね
それは前に説明しましたから
何業？支持業と妨害業がありますから
だからそこら辺でまた運命変えますけど
ですから支持業もまた悔しいんです
この 働きは業の働きは決して面白い話じゃないんです
例えば人があまり贅沢しないで贅沢をできるような環境で生まれたんだと
それでも贅沢しないでよく勉強するわ
よく努力するわ ものすごい行儀よく生きていると
その人にはこのサポート
指示業がついてくるんです
いわゆる幸福になってくると
何だかんだ幸福の方向へ回っちゃうんです
そこでその人が突然不幸になったとすると
全部不幸ばっかり 例えばお金はもうもう十分やと思う時は
いろんな人々からお金入るんです
その時は自分にお金ありすぎと
誰かが来てちょっとお金貸してくださいと
投資何か商売やりますからと言ったら
あなたにもちゃんと利益あげますよと言って
それで私のお金要りませんと
もうもう十分あるんだからと
とにかくもうどうでもいいんだから持って行けと
お金あげたとします この人はすごい幸福なんです
いくらでもお金が入るわ入るわ
収入はあるわ そこでその人からお金借りた人ももう商売うまくいっちゃって
またこの人にあなたのおかげでもう投資ってデビタんだからあなたの取り分だとも
それからまた入るようになっちゃうんです
本当は入れないんですね
それでその人の株暴落して急にもうダメになったとすると
そこでお金貸した人のところに行って
あなたにお金貸して私は利息も取ってないんだと
一部返しと言ったらお金ないんだ
他にその時でしょ その時ないじゃないですか
そこでまた自分の株が上がったりしたりところで
あの人も じゃああなたの利息はこの年分もうもう年分溜まってるんだから全部上納と
その時は別にどうでもいいんですけど
で もっとわかりやすい例で言うならば
自分がケーキ食べたくて
ケーキ今年食べたいなと思って
手頃のいいケーキ屋さん
そこら辺に行ってケーキ買って食べたんだと
食べてよかったなと思ったところで
誰かが友達がそのケーキ買って持ってくるんですね
もういいんです 食べてるんだから
前に持ってきた方がもっと面白いんだけど
だいたいこの業っていうのは
このこのサポートする業もそういう風にいらん時はよくサポートしてくるんです
指示業も妨害業 それも決して誰かが悪いことをからくりやってるわけじゃない
そういう法則なんです
そういう法則  [背景音楽]で
どこかへ出かけをしたところで
足がもうひねっちゃって
階段から下りた もう何て言いますか
下りたんじゃなくて落ちたと
そこでなんとか痛くて
それでも行かなくちゃいけない買い物
もうやっと足を引きずりながら行くと
後ろから来て自転車が自分の体にぶつかる
で つなげてくるんです
同じものが だから世の中にあるでしょう
不幸になるともう次から次へと不幸だと
ついてるともう次から次へとなんだかんだでついてるんだと
そこら辺理解する人にとっては
自分の業のプログラムすることはできます
それはもう避けられないことで
例えば自分がすごい健康的ですごいもう問題ないんだ
ジョギングをしているんだと
この人ジョギングしていると
自転車が後ろから来たとしても
何のことなく避けることできるし
自転車の人はこの人ジョギングしているんだからということ
よく見えるんだから自転車のコントロールできるし
これ足が痛くてもう引きずってやっと歩く人は
この人左に来るか右に来るか
後ろの自転車に乗ってる人わからないんですね
それでぶつかってしまっちゃうんです
そういうふうなことで
この一旦人間で生まれていれば
我々にはこの指示業も妨害業も働きますけど
それまた良かったっていう風にほっとすることもまたできないんですね
いらない時はもうちゃんといらないことをやってくれる
不幸になったら いくらでももう次から次へと不幸になる
自分の何て言いますか
保険が切れたら病気になるんです
すいません 一生で一つの業を使う話
一生で一つの業を使って一人になる話
そこにいろんな業がちょっかい出してくれる
出してくるっていうのはどういう仕組み？一つの業で生きているんだけど
複数の業が  そのシステムですね
それは説明してないんですね
生まれた後が管理するのはその人の寿命と性格と基本的なプログラムですね
だから何歳で死ぬかとかね
死ぬまでそこはメインの命ですか
メインラインのコントロールする
決勝ゴールしちゃうじゃなくて
そうそう だからそこですから
ですから 考え方も一応全部基本的なものは全部コントロールする
知識はどれぐらいかとかね
体力はどれぐらいだとかね
で それにこのいろんな業がカルマ
心の中にいつでも活動しているんだから
その中でちょっと穴があったらすぐ一つ飛び出しちゃうんです
空きがあったら 飛び出したら
でもサポートすることしかできない
サポートするか妨害することしかできない
まあ突然新しいカルマが表に出たら
その人死ぬこともありますけどね
あまりにもひどい妨害したところで
でも死ぬということは生をせた
生まれを作った業がしちゃうんですね
で まあ経典やら仏教では一般的にそれ言ってるんですけど
そのメカニズムは説明してないんです
その代わりに言うのは
やっぱり例えば人が清らかな心でいると
悪いカルマには結果出すことはできないと
例えば人が貧しく生まれたんだけど
それを上 嘘をついたりするともっと貧しくなる
貧しく生まれたんだけど
正直者で働き者で すごい謙虚的で
だったら誰か助けてあげちゃうんですね
この今世の心の働きが問題ないんだから
であの人 大変働き者で正直者で
働いたってお金もなかなか入る方もないし
まあいいんじゃないか
助けてあげましょうという気持ちに人々がなる
そこで人々はその人を助けてあげる
その場合は その人の指示業が働いて助けてくれる
指示業に指示業現れたのは
その人の今世の心の回転のコントロールなんですね
ですから やっぱり今世の生き方も大変大事ということは
我々具体的には言うんですね
倫理的な立場で 過去の業に悩むんじゃなくて
過去の業はもう決まったもんだから放っておきましょうと
生まれてから我々はどのように生きているかと
そういうことによって自分の人生を